>> Bret: IT NOW TO REACTION OF
THAT IG REPORT FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING THE
DAY OFF ESSENTIALLY FROM PUBLIC
EVENTS, CELEBRATING HIS 72ND
OVERSHADOWED BY A LEGAL
CHALLENGE COMING OUT OF NEW YORK
TO THE PRESIDENT'S CHARITABLE
FOUNDATION.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE
REPORTS FOR US TONIGHT.
>> CERTAINLY, THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS IN THIS REPORT THAT NOT
ONLY WORRY THOSE OF US IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT SHOULD WORRY
A LOT OF AMERICANS.
>> Reporter: EVEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY OFFERED ITS
FULL THROATED SUPPORT FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT, IT
WAS A LAWSUIT FROM
NEW YORK STATE THAT REALLY GOT
THE WHITE HOUSE'S ATTENTION.
>> OF THE CURRENT ACTING
NEW YORK AG HAS STATED THAT
BATTLING THE WHITE HOUSE IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT JOB SHE HAS EVER
DONE.
THAT SOUNDS OUTRAGEOUSLY BIASED
AND CERTAINLY PROBLEMATIC.
>> Reporter: IN IT, STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARBARA
UNDERWOOD ACCUSES THE TRUMP
FOUNDATION OF ILLEGAL CONDUCT,
INCLUDING COORDINATING WITH THE
CURRENT PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN
2016.
THE SUIT AIMS TO DISSOLVE THE
TRUMP FOUNDATION, A OBTAIN
RESTITUTION OF $3 MILLION AND
INCLUDES REFERRAL LETTERS TO
BOTH THE IRS AND FEC.
THE SUIT ALLEGES THE TERM
FOUNDATION ILLEGALLY PROVIDED
EXTENSIVE SUPPORT TO ITS 2016
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, WITH
UNDER WAY TO CALLING THE CHARITY
OF A LITTLE MORE THAN A
CHECKBOOK FOR PAYMENTS FROM
MR. TRUMP AND HIS BUSINESSES TO
NONPROFITS, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
PURPOSE OR LEGALITY.
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARY
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUAR2
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUAR1
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUAR6
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARE
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARA
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARL
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARF
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARO
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARM
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARF
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARR
INVESTIGATORS POINT TO A JANUARE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER, ASKING
FOR MONEY FOR VETERANS CHARITIES
AND I LIVE JUST BEFORE THE
CAUCUSES THEY ARE.
INDEED, THE AG'S OFFICE SAID IT
GAVE FIVE, $100,000 GRANTS WERE
MADE THEY ARE RIGHT BEFORE THE
VOTES WERE CAST IN THE HAWKEYE
STATE.
BUT THE PRESIDENT PUSHED BACK ON
TWITTER: NEW YORK DEMOCRATS
SLEAZY, SAYING THEY ARE SUING A
FOUNDATION THAT TOOK IN
$8.8 MILLION AND GAVE OUT TO
CHARITY MORE MONEY THAN IT TOOK
HIM TO COME UP 19.2 MILLION.
I WON'T SETTLE THIS CASE.
THE TRUMP FOUNDATION ADDED SO
SIMPLY, THIS IS POLITICS AT ITS
VERY WORST.
THE SUIT IS JUST THE LATEST IN A
STEADY STREAM OF LEGAL ACTIONS
AIMED AT THE PRESIDENT OR HIS
ASSOCIATES.
FROM FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR MIKE FLYNN AND FORM OF
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER PAUL
MANAFORT TO THE SUIT BROUGHT BY
ADULT FILM PERFORMER STORMY
DANIELS, AND PERSISTENT I WAS
ACCUSATIONS THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS VIOLATED THE CONSTITUTION'S
AND'S EMOLUMENTS CLAUSE.
HIS CHILDREN ARE ALSO NAMED IN A